es gibt ein verb das eine ganz besondere
rolle im deutschen hat und ihr habt uns
schon oft gefragt ob wir mal ein video
darüber machen können
und genau das machen wir heute heute
geht es um das verb lassen
der grund warum ihr das verb lassen
wahrscheinlich schwierig findet manchmal
ist dass es wirklich ganz verschiedene
bedeutungen haben kann der duden listet
bis zu neuen bedeutungen und was
besonders interessant ist ist das das
verb auch in anderen sprachen je nach
kontext ganz unterschiedlich übersetzt
wird so werdet ihr zum beispiel in
diesem video sehen wie wir das
verblassen mit let lief oder auch to get
down oder to have done übersetzen werden
und das ist wahrscheinlich auch schon
das schwierigste was ihr euch merken
müssen und was ihr euch merken muss das
einfach ihr könnt euch wahrscheinlich
nicht alle bedeutungen gleichzeitig
merken
deshalb wollen wir euch in diesem video
einige der wichtigsten bedeutungen und
situationen vorstellen in denen ihr das
verb lassen benutzen könnt die erste
bedeutung von lassen die wir euch in
diesem video vorstellen ist wenn man mit
etwas aufhört oder etwas nicht macht wie
ihr vielleicht wisst kann man das ein
ganz oft mit anderen werden kombinieren
lassen kann jedoch auch alleine stehen
und immer wenn es alleine steht als
einziges web in einem satz dann bedeutet
es so etwas wie aufhören oder etwas
nicht machen
hier seht ihr ein beispiel
die finger karriere mein fahrrad aber
ich kann das gar nicht
ich gebe auf ich lasse es gehört lassen
in diesem kontext auch besonders häufig
im imperativ also immer dann wenn man
andere zu etwas auffordert zum beispiel
las dass dann möchte man dass sie etwas
nicht tun oder mit etwas aufhören
[Musik]
das dach sei nichts was mich einfach
alleine in diesem letzten szenen ging es
also darum dass man etwas nicht macht
oder jemand anderen dazu auffordert
etwas nicht zu machen
jetzt schauen wir uns noch mal eine
andere bedeutung von lassen an
und in diesen szenen seht ihr das lassen
dort so etwas heißt wie erlauben oder
ermöglichen hier seht ihr ein beispiel
das lässt du mich auch mal spielen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gerade wenn man mit kindern oder über
kinder redet benutzt man diese variante
von lassen besonders häufig man kann zum
beispiel sagen ich lasse meine kinder
heute länger aufbleiben oder ich lasse
meine kinder nur eine stunde am tag
fernseh gucken und in diesen fällen
heißt lassen immer so etwas wie erlauben
oder ermöglichen
übrigens wenn ihr etwas mehr lernen
möchte über dieses verb und auch selbst
aktiv werden möchtet dann empfehlen wir
euch unsere interaktiven übungen die sie
und sophie bereiten die jede woche für
euch vor und in dieser woche könnt ihr
lernen wie ihr setzte mit lassen bildet
um diese übung zu bekommen könnt ihr ein
mitglied von diese german werden das
geht hierbei patchen und damit
unterstützt ihr auch unsere arbeit
die nächste bedeutung von lassen die wir
euch vorstellen ist wenn man etwas nicht
selber machen kann oder nicht selber
machen will und dann kann man so etwas
sagen wie ich lasse mir die haare
schneiden oder ich lasse mein fahrrad
reparieren und diese konstruktionen sind
manchmal schwierig für euch denn man
kann damit auch den akkusativ benutzen
und den dativ man benutzt es eigentlich
immer mit akkusativ man sagt dann so was
wie ich lasse meine haare schneiden hier
braucht man den akkusativ wenn man auch
noch sich selber inkludiert dann muss
man auch noch den dativ nutzen
ich lasse mir die haare schneiden oder
er lässt sich die haare schneiden
der garten sie ganz schön scheiße aus
wir brauchen unbedingt eine neue hecke
machst du das selber
nein wir lassen es machen
eine besonders nützliche variante von
lassen ist die freundliche aufforderung
und das ist nützlich für euch weil ihr
das direkt auf der straße mit euren
freunden benutzen könnt wenn ihr zum
beispiel unterwegs seid in einer gruppe
und ihr überlegt was ihr machen wollt
dann könnt ihr so etwas sagen wie lass
uns doch koreanisch essen gehen oder
lasst uns doch noch ein bier trinken
lasst uns irgend etwas schönes machen
ja was denn spazieren gehen warum nicht
gerne
okay lass uns noch fast schöneres machen
was denn das uns ein bier kaufen und
damit spazieren gehen na gut
ja
die letzte bedeutung von lassen die wir
euch in diesem video vorstellen ist wenn
man etwas nicht mitnimmt
ich kann zum beispiel so janisch sagen
wenn wir losgehen nimmst du deine jacke
mit und er antwortet dann darauf die
lasse ich hier
hier ist noch ein beispiel muss das bier
ich habe leute mit zwei siege dass ihr
gesehen habt gibt es ganz
unterschiedliche bedeutungen zu dem verb
lassen und wir haben euch heute nur die
wichtigsten oder vielleicht auch die
nützlichsten für die alltagssprache
vorgestellt wenn ihr alle neuen
bedeutungen mal durchlesen und lernen
möchtet dann verlinken wir euch noch den
duden eintrag zum verb lassen
dort könnt ihr etwas mehr erfahren und
wenn ihr lust habt jetzt ein bisschen
selbst zu üben mit diesem werk dann
guckt euch doch mal unsere interaktiven
übungen an die easy und sophie auch
diese woche wieder für euch vorbereitet
haben um die zu bekommen könnt ihr
einfach ein mitglied bei uns werden das
geht bei katrin dot com / german danke
fürs zu sehen und bis bald
[Musik]
jakl an der jacke
und klar
in bar
[Musik]
reicht